- the redgrave family all the world's a
stage and they're playing all the parts
to present the art-direction awards we
have Miss Vanessa Redgrave who is
currently starring in three of the top
movies of the year to find an escort
worthy of her was no simple matter I was
working so we have to settle for Rock
Hudson
well we're very happy to be here only
because we're going to announce the
nominees for the black and white art
direction and the winner and then we
will announce the nominees for the color
art Direction nominees for the best
achievement in art direction black and
white are Robert Luther for the fortune
cookie decoration by Edward G Boyle we
just got your note cheer for the Gospel
according to st. Matthew
Willie Holt is Paris burning set
decoration by Marc Frederick's and
Pierre guffawing George W Davis and Paul
Gross mr. Beaudoin set decoration by
Henry grace and Hugh hunt
Richard Silbert Who's Afraid of Virginia
Woolf set decoration by George James
Hopkins
yes the winner is Richard silver for
Who's Afraid of Virginia row and George
D
thank you very much
there are always a great many people
have thanked in the making of this film
and I do thank them all I'd like to
thank a young director whose first
picture it was my good fortune to work
with Amon against Mike Nichols thank you
I also have to thank our sleiman who is
many kindnesses
and now for the best achievement in
color art direction the nominees are
Jack Martin Smith and Dale Hennessy for
Fantastic Voyage set decoration by water
em Scott and Stewart a breeze
Alexander golitsin and Georgia C Webb
for gambit set decoration by John
McCarthy and John Austin Piero Girardi
Juliet experience how Pereira and Arthur
Lonnegan for the Oscar set decoration by
Robert Benton and James Payne Boris
Levin the sand colors set decoration by
Walter M Scott John Sturdivant and
William Coonan may I have them the
winners are Jack Martin Smith and Dale
Hennessy fantastic
I have an idea the four of us look more
like a polo team because they're just
for believe me we all four of us have a
lot to thank tomorrow when they go back
to the studio a whole lot full of people
who helped make this picture possible
thank you so much
very special thanks to Frank Armitage
Tom graves art Crookshanks and Ernie
Lazlo thank you very much